Speaker 1: One of the most notable differences
right now between the Democratic and Republican
parties outside of ideology is that
the Republican Party not only isn't
ashamed to nominate and elect people who just
can't think, whose brains really don't work,
they almost seem proud of it in some
strange way. And one such person is radical
Republican congresswoman from Georgia,
Marjorie Taylor. GREENE fresh off the
primary win that she had last week, who now
has left again using the term peach tree dish
rather than petri dish. Now we'll get to that. And
when I say she's gassed again, I'll remind you at
one point trying to talk about some kind of COVID
Gestapo using the term gazpacho, which is, of
course, a cold Spanish tomato soup, sometimes with
a cucumber in it, which I think is a nice thing to
add to gazpacho. Okay. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Not only do we have the D.C. jail,
which is the D.C. gulag, but now
we have Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho,
police spying on members of Congress.
Speaker 1: Now, some people speculated she does
this on purpose to get attention. No, she doesn't.
There is absolutely no evidence whatsoever
that she has any idea about the word gazpacho
versus Gestapo. There is absolutely no reason
to think that, well, she's done it again. And this
time she's talking about fake meats. And she seems
to think that fake meat is grown, not in a petri
dish, which is, of course, you know, a little
plastic container for holding cells, bacteria,
whatever that it is. A peach tree dish is a dish
in which you put a tree that grows peaches.
Speaker 2: You have to accept the fact that
the government totally wants to provide
surveillance on every part of your life.
They want to know when you're eating. They
want to know if you're eating a cheeseburger,
which is very bad because Bill Gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that grows in a peach tree dish.
A peach tree dish. You'll probably get a little
zap inside your body and that say, no, no, don't
eat a real cheeseburger. You need to eat the fake
the fake burger, the fake meat from Bill Gates.
Speaker 1: Okay. So it's just a gaffe, right? I
mean, who cares? Well, it's actually much bigger
than just any individual gaffe. These people
can barely put together a coherent thought. And
it doesn't matter. We have a political party. We
have members of a political party in this country
that don't care about the fact that their
candidates can't think, they can't think,
and they still vote for them. In normal countries,
these folks would not stand a chance at being in
positions of power, and they'll come back
and say, Oh, how elitist, David. You think
only people who use real words and can speak and
think a little bit should be able to be in? Well,
I'm not saying it should be illegal for them to
run. What I'm saying is that a sane country would
never vote for these people. Look at what's going
on with Herschel Walker in the Senate. We played
these clips last week, but I'll include them
here because they're relevant. Herschel Walker is
endorsed by Trump. Former football player won his
Senate primary in Georgia essentially unopposed.
He can't speak. He can't think. Okay. Here he
was asked by CNN reporter Manu Raju whether
there should be any new gun laws. And his answer
was, What I like to do is see it in everything
and stuff that that's the whole answer.
Speaker 4: Hey, why don't Roger with
CNN. I know, but are you just bringing new
gun laws in the wake of this Texas shootings?
You support new gun laws in the wake of
what I like to do, what I like to see.
Speaker 3: And and everything and
stuff. I like to see it, you know.
Speaker 1: He likes to see it and everything and
stuff. Then the next day he appeared on Fox News
and he said he would solve school shootings
with a department that can look at young men,
looking at young women, looking at
social media. That's the solution.
Speaker 3: See, there is a person will in that
weapon, you know, Cain kill Abel, you know,
and you. And that's a problem that we have. And I
said, what we need to do is look into how we can
stop those things. You know, he talked about doing
a disinformation. What about getting a department
that can look at young men that's looking at
women, they're looking at social media? What
about doing that? Looking into things like.
Speaker 1: Okay, so that's his idea.
We want to get a department that can
look at young men looking at women,
looking at social media. They cannot speak. They
cannot think. And it doesn't dissuade Republicans.
It doesn't dissuade Republicans. And so the
question becomes, how can you defeat a movement?
Whose elected officials don't even
have to have a functioning brain.
And that doesn't even dissuade the voters. It
doesn't seem like reality matters anymore. And
so how do you defeat that, I guess. Voter
turnout on our side. But I mean, listen,
that you we say that every year and then
there's always like so-so voter turnout,
particularly in midterms. So I don't
know I don't know what to tell you.